so you think you know spiders think they
all spin web sketch insects and wrap
their victims up and something juices
out think again this is a crap job
spider and it doesn't need any stinking
soap to hunt those huge jobs are closing
in just in half a millisecond not half a
second half a millisecond it's so fast
the scientists studying them couldn't
even see them striking until now
high-speed video has finally revealed a
new way for spiders to raise hell yet
it's not quite clear how the chapter on
spider is pulling this off somehow it
stores energy Nets oversized head and
releases it in one sudden catastrophic
blow interestingly a group advanced of a
similar facial situations the trap-jaw
ant's have such a powerful strike that
they can aim their faces at the ground
and blast themselves out of danger
that's pretty damn amazing having two
totally unrelated species evolving a
bear trap or a face this is called
convergent evolution or just totally
badass
your call so watch your step little
critters
you